i don't know how many of you are
familiar with liz harrington liz
harrington is donald trump's
sort of soviet-style spokeswoman um she
you know north korean propaganda agents
have seen liz harrington
and her videos and it makes them blush
it's really something else
um she is making the unfounded claim and
this is sort of you know we've seen it
evolve over time first it was the fbi
planted the documents then it was there
were no documents then it was they were
there but they were trump's right to
have because he declassified them but
the classification didn't matter so then
it was back to well the fbi plan it's a
circle it's just a revolving door it's
like a hamster wheel
of throwing a bunch of stuff at the wall
to see what sticks
liz harrington is now going back to
biden and his administration have
directed this entire thing check out her
interview on the water cooler
on real america's voice how much do you
think the biden administration is
involved in with this specifically joe
biden then again with joe biden we're
never quite sure what he knows uh at
this point with all the phone calls but
uh what's your sense about the biden
administration how much do you think
this is going to trail back to them
well i mean
similarly to what happened with the
russia gate right i mean it's mostly the
largely the russia game same people
that were involved in the obama biden
administration and the setting up the
false accusations of russia collusion
with the clinton campaign but that was
all spun into motion during the
transition period
uh using you know this
law fair but also the intelligence
community against their political
opponents so i think they're very much
involved i think it's very much the same
people
and that's what we really need i think
to your point david the answers to
we need accountability here yeah and so
she says it's obvious that biden was
very very involved
and also throwing in during another
moment of the interview trump can have
whatever the hell he wants at his house
the big question still does remain about
why president trump had these records
there down at mar-a-lago in the first
place is there anything you can tell us
about that i think that's kind of one
thing that's still been out there people
trying to understand that at least the
lay person is trying to understand
because it's completely not
understandable unless it's for nefarious
regions reasons or unless trump wants to
pretend to still be president
i think the key point here is the
presidential
records act
presidential he's the president and the
fake news media is trying to pretend
that he wasn't or that he was just some
you know paper pusher like these
bureaucrats at the national archives no
he's the president his correspondent he
had every right to keep whatever he
wants
uh and
uh possess whatever he wanted to and
obviously when he left the white house
he took some documents with him it was
his prerogative now understand that not
only is that not true it doesn't
actually answer the question the
question was why did trump want the
documents
and there really is no benign
explanation it's
the explanations go from bad to very
very bad to really really bad like
treason is bad and her answer is both
not an answer to the question but it's
also not true that he can just take
whatever he wants even republican
strategist karl rove said on fox news
the other night these are simply not
trump's documents to take
you don't just declassify things by
saying i wish them declassified and
things are not de facto declassified
because trump you know stuck him in his
pants or in a box and took them to his
house so
really just soviet-style propaganda
there
from liz harrington
and
we have to hope here's the hope okay
i've said before i think trump's getting
indicted i don't think he's going to
prison
there has been a lot of really bad stuff
that went on here
and it seems clear
that at least some people committed
crimes
if no one ends up seeing consequences
for what has gone on
um
it will be a major indictment of the
two-tiered american justice system not
that we need more indictments of it it's
been indicted plenty we've seen that
over the last decade
but it would be a real injustice if
there are no consequences for what went
down and all we can do is continue to
wait and see